NOW 19 WINS SHY OF 300EASON
AT THE HANDS OF THE FLYERS.
>> John S.: NET
ALMOST GAVE IT
CENTRE AND CHIPS IT TO
THE CORNER, GOINGP ANOTHER CLEAN
TWO-ON-ONE BUT IT ENDED UP OFF
ANAHEIMOR WITHO SCHENN
HERE, THE FEED THAT TIME IS
BAILEY, CHIPPING THAT PUCK OFF E
BACK TO SCHENN WIT
AND THAT WAS A WINGER WIN.
HERE NOW THE SET PLAY THAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT.
AS YOU SEEEFT
POINT.
LAMMIKKO.
8:30 INTO THISER, HIT THE
POST!
THAT SHOOT-IN TO THE CORNER ANDH
SEELER.
AND HERE TOPODKOLZIN, BANKING
THAT PUCK HERE TO CENTRE A ZONE.
>> John G.: OH, BOY, HALAK AND T
THERE 1:40, OUT SAVE, HALAK ANDE
T
ZACK MacEWEN WHO FELT THAT ONE
AND, OH, BOY,CHECKED. THAT PART,
TIME TO HIGHMORE.
QUICK SHOT, SHARP ANGLE, IS LINH
THE PUCK GIVEN UP.
COUTURIER,ohn S.: AND THE CANUCS
MIGHT BE MISSING
PLAY GOES ON A AND IT LAMMIKKO
HERE TOE LINE AND THAT
PUCK, HITS A IT THECE HERE, KON,
>> John S.: AND I LIKE THE
RELEASE OF COUTURIER O OBENCH.
MILL THE PASS TO BOESER,
SHOVELING THAT PUCK TO
ELIAS PETTERSSON WHO DUMPS